hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda saga level for 80
commentary walkthrough with tips was a
pretty tough level that it took a little
while to figure out so I wanted to add
some tips in this new video I made today
the coils at the bottom earth or the
real problem get in the jam the spread
around the top isn't too bad at all
but the way the board's laid out you
can't really even hit them except the
striked candies are fish in the
beginning and one thing that I noticed
when I was making this took me quite a
few tries was that when you use in the
beginning if you spread the jam and then
say you set off a fish the fish if the
fish is on on Jam and it'll spread to
one of these squares at the top of the
board to you know to spread the jam but
if it's not if it's a dry square there
you're sending it off from then it'll go
after the coil so you kind of want to do
that as soon as you can so I'm going to
go ahead and get in you can see I have a
color bomb set up here in the beginning
and it's also gonna set up a fish match
which is pretty nice so I can drop the
color bomb off there so I got enough
orange candies on the board spread out
that aren't on the jam so those are all
going to turn into fish and go after the
coils so that's an easy no-brainer type
decision there and this will actually
you know give me some room at the bottom
so I'm not gonna really focus too much
on spreading the jam at first because I
know that that'll happen so I'm just
gonna try to you know put together fish
and other combos so that I can get some
more of those coils out of the way at
the bottom
I'm definitely trying to these holes in
the board in the shape rather you kind
of make it tough but definitely want to
look things over carefully so that you
don't miss anything so here we have
another Leon fish but we can't set it
off we have a bomb up top wrapped candy
up top that we can use soon Sparkle
shell also come in handy here ever
sprinkle chaat I should say and one of
the the thing about sprinkle shell is
when you use him he's not going to if
you have used them for a color that's
next to the coils it's not gonna help
but also I'm just gonna go ahead and get
rid of these coils first before I set
them off and then I can use them to get
that ice right there like set off the
blue and then I'll give me a hit on the
ice so we're doing pretty good at this
point we got 23 moves left and we've
already got all the coils out of the way
for the most part we're not out of the
woods this wraps up strike to the top
will help a lot as far as spreading some
jam and getting rid of that ice there is
a wrapped candy behind nice all the time
so that's a little bonus and the ice on
the corners also have the up striped
candies in them so definitely will come
in handy I'm gonna make this fish first
see how they fall I'm not gonna set that
off and pretty much anything any fish or
anything that we set off at this point
it's going to pretty much go towards the
we got a color bomb here but I'm gonna
go ahead and fire that off first those
stripes on the sides aim toward the ices
it's gonna be are gonna be a big help
and the color bomb now isn't really
gonna do a whole lot so I'm going to
just go ahead and work on the rest of us
to have 16 moves left so no real reason
to just fire off the color bomb
without making it into a combo or
something double fish will be good here
that'll finish off any leftover squares
that don't have jam for the most part so
now most of the fish I make from this
point except for one will go right up to
the ice and I'm just taking my time
still at this point well you know
they're striped on the side what should
be good if we can set that off and this
is just a matter of taking our time
apart of the best match usually if you
can get rid of all the coils that you
pay attention here we go there's a fish
with the with the collar bomb mister
prolly get us and set up really nice but
yeah if you you know if you can get rid
of those coils pretty quickly you're
gonna be a good way of the way there I'm
going to go ahead and match these two
stripes first cuz they'll get another
hit and then I'm gonna use the sprinkler
shell on the blue because it should
charge it right back up and there are
two blue fish also and then here I like
using it on the orange because the
orange candy is next to the last piece
ice so that'll hit that set off the fish
and then that also set off the fish on
the other side so there we go so like I
said this is a tough level it took a
while the biggest thing I took away from
it is that fact that you don't really
need to start out spreading the jam you
really need to try to look for fish and
fish combos to get rid of some of the
coils at the bottom and you always want
to check down there once they start to
fall to see if you can make any matches
because it only really takes a few nice
matches in the bottom to get rid of the
rest of them once you get things started
so that's about it it's a tough level
just cuz you know how to do it doesn't
mean that you'll finish it off right
away but follow what I did and keep
those things in mind and you'll get it
soon hope this helped so please like the
video
and subscribe to my channel and I'll see
you soon